nasa has been around the league for
quite a while now but it's a perfect
time he make the announcement today
nasa wearing number 94 at camp last week
in his
video post he says he's a private person
not doing this for attention
but saying he actually hopes that one
day videos like the one he put out today
on instagram
and the whole coming out process won't
be necessary but until that day he says
he'll do his best to cultivate a culture
that's accepting and compassionate
and he's doing more than just making the
announcement and i'm going to start by
donating 100 000
to the trevor project they're an
incredible organization they're the
number one
suicide prevention service for lgbtq
youth in america
and they're truly doing incredible
things and i'm very excited to be
a part of it to help in any way that i
can and i'm really pumped to see what
the future holds
all right nasa making the post from his
home in pennsylvania today the raiders
have next month off they report to the
henderson training facility
at the end of july denise